-Well, guys, it's Monday night,
and you know what that means.
It's "Tonight's Show"
Trivia Night.
Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ "Tonight Show"
Trivia Night ♪
-Yeah, fun. I love trivia.
Higgins, you want to explain
how this works?
-I would love to.
Yes, Jimmy,
to test your knowledge
on a wide variety of topics,
I'm going to be asking you
a series of trivia questions,
and all you have to do
is answer them correctly.
Alright, it's easy,
I love trivia. Let's do this.
-Ready? First question.
What is the most secure place
in the United States?
-Um, Fort Knox.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, close.
The deodorant aisle at CVS.
[ Laughter ]
So close, so close.
Okay, ready?
Whose slogan is
"Snap, Crackle, Pop"?
-Easy. Rice Krispies.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, no. Incorrect.
Joe Biden when he stands up.
[ Laughter ]
Almost. You almost got it.
Almost got it.
Alright, Jimmy, ready?
-Yep.
-What question have scholars
tried to answer for centuries?
-"What is the meaning of life?"
[ Buzzer ]
-Judges?
No, "Why is pickleball
so popular?"
[ Laughter ]
For centuries.
-I don't know why.
For hundreds of years,
they've been trying
to answer that.
Alright, Jimmy,
you'll get this one.
Twitter changed its name, right?
What do people call it now?
-X.
[ Buzzer ]
-Wrong. Twitter.
They call it Twitter.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ah, yeah.
-You almost got it.
You almost got it.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, ready?
You're going to get this one,
I know.
-Mm-hmm.
What's the most common place
for senior citizens --
where do they go
to enjoy their golden years?
Senior citizens?
Where do they go?
-Florida.
[ Buzzer ]
-No. Congress. Congress.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"Preach!"
-Preach.
-That was my political --
That's from my stand-up act.
-Your stand-up act, by the way.
Yeah, I got to make it.
-You got to go see it.
I take a newspaper, I just riff.
-No, I'm busy.
-Oh, really, what are you doing?
-Very busy.
-What about tomorrow?
-That's Halloween.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, ready?
-I love this.
-What is the hardest
thing on earth?
What is the hardest
Don't get --
-What is the hardest thing?
-The hardest thing on Earth.
It's a family show.
-Not getting sexual.
-I don't know. A family show.
-What is the hardest
thing on earth?
-Yes, what is the hardest
thing on Earth?
-Diamond.
-Wrong!
[ Buzzer ]
-Canceling a gym membership.
-Oh, yeah, that's it.
That is right, that is correct.
-One more.
-That is right.
-Okay.
-This one's worth
a million points.
-Mm-hmm.
-So if you win this one,
you win the whole thing.
Ready?
-Yep.
Who do experts predict
will be this year's NFL MVP?
This year's NFL MVP.
-Taylor Swift.
-Yes!
[ Bell dings ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thank you.
That is all the time we have.
Stick around.
We'll be right back
with more "Tonight Show,"
everybody!